nach langem hin und her in der koalition
der bundestag stimmt für die grundrente
1,3 millionen menschen sollen davon
profitieren so viele wie noch nie die
usa verzeichnet fast 53.000 corona
infektionen an nur einem tag
einige bundesstaaten machen restaurants
und bars wieder zu touristen dringend
erwünscht eine türkische
regierungsstellen aktion wirbt in
deutschland dafür dass die reisewarnung
aufgehoben wird ohne erfolg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen schön gut an bei
uns katja stresow hat nachher den sport
nach einem langen berufsleben im alter
keine armut leiden das ist die idee
hinter der grundrente die jetzt
beschlossen ist nach langem streit wer
jahrzehntelang wenig verdient hat wenig
in die rentenkasse einzahlt soll später
zumindest eine basisversorgung haben
mehr geld für 1,3 millionen menschen
der bundestag hat heute grünes licht
gegeben da wird sauer erklärt wem die
grundrente was bringt voll gezahlt wird
die grundrente nur bis zu einem
bestimmten freibetrag 1250 euro im monat
für alleinstehende und 1950 euro für
paare
jeder euro einkommen über diesen
freibetrag wird teilweise angerechnet
alles über 1600 bei alleinstehenden
beziehungsweise 2300 euro bei paaren
wird voll angerechnet also je höher das
einkommen desto niedriger der anspruch
auf grundrente ein beispiel jemand hat
40 jahre lang zum mindestlohn gearbeitet
das macht bislang 512 euro
rentenanspruch mit grundrente wird auf
961 euro aufgestockt ein antrag ist
nicht nötig per datenaustausch zwischen
rentenversicherung und finanzbehörden
wird der anspruch automatisch geprüft
vermögen und immobilien werden nicht
berücksichtigt die kosten bis zu 1,6
milliarden euro im jahr sollten
ursprünglich über eine
finanztransaktionssteuer gedeckt werden
deren einführung stockt aber und jetzt
kommt das geld aus dem bundeshaushalt
langer streit in der regierungskoalition
heute stimmten union und spd für die
grundrente afd und fdp dagegen grüne und
linke enthielten sich die debatte zeigt
cornelia schiemenz
am ende klatscht sogar die union fast
ein jahr haben sich cdu und csu gegen
den gesetzentwurf der spd zur grundrente
gesträubt nun nach langem ringen der
kompromiss die grundrente ist das
lieblingsprojekt der sozialdemokraten
und laut arbeitsminister das zentrale
reformvorhaben der bundesregierung
es ist richtig gut dass diese regierung
gerade in diesen zeiten beweist dass man
zu guten lösungen gemeinschaftlich auch
in der lage ist zu bringen um die beste
lösung mit unterschiedlichen positionen
ist keine schande aber nicht zu
ergebnissen zu kommen das wäre eine
schande gewesen liebe kolleginnen liebe
liegen die spd wollte die grundrente
ursprünglich für weit mehr menschen vor
allem aber sollte es keine
bedarfsprüfung geben die hat die union
nun durchgesetzt dies kann ist zwar
einfach aber sie ist eben auch ungerecht
und deswegen muss zielgenau ein bedarf
festgestellt werden denn unkompliziert
aber ungerecht wäre nicht der bessere
weg die linke hätte gern mit gestimmt
aber der nun gefundene kompromiss sei
für sie untragbar weil zu wenig menschen
profitieren werden viele werden
frustriert sein weil sie die 33
beitragsjahre nicht schaffen zb wegen
eines jahres arbeitslosigkeit das
konzept der grundrente ist zu teuer
sozial ungerecht wirkungslos und
belastet die folge generation
die spd ist am ziel die grundrente für
die sie so viele jahre gekämpft hat
kommt doch auf dem weg dahin mussten die
sozialdemokraten die eine oder andere
kröte schlucken und die analyse jetzt
von theo koll aus berlin theo was hat
denn jetzt dazu geführt dass die
grundrente tatsächlich eine mehrheit
gefunden hat hat diese sache politisch
einen gewinner
ja ich glaube der größere gewinner ist
sicher die spd denn sie hat viele ihrer
vorstellung war der grundrente
durchsetzen können für die union ging es
vor allem darum beim wähler nicht zum
verlierer zu werden und als blockierer
dazu stehen schon gar nicht vor einem
mega war ja in dem nicht nur der
bundestag neu gewählt wird sondern auch
viele landtage davon einige in den
östlichen bundesländern wo besonders
viele künftige bezieher von grundrechten
leben und wählen und sich gegen die
grundrechte zu stellen wenn gleichzeitig
für die pandemie folgen 100
dann fließen auch dass wir politisch ja
nicht mehr durchzuhalten wenn man sich
das kleingedruckte anschaut dann sieht
man aber dass auch die union noch
einiges erreicht hat der bedarf wird in
jedem fall geprüft und die förderung der
betriebsrenten wird deutlich erhöht auch
das hat die union am ende noch
nachverhandelt theo vielen dank die
bundestagsabgeordneten haben heute auch
das konjunkturpaket in der korona krise
verabschiedet das bedeutet rekord
schulden von 217,8 milliarden euro fast
fünfmal so viel wie im bisherigen rekord
schulden jahr 2010 auch thema im
bundestag pauschaltouristen deren urlaub
wegen der pandemie abgesagt wurde können
jetzt wählen zwischen rückerstattung des
geldes und einem gutschein
außerdem setzten die
koalitionsfraktionen nach monatelangen
diskussionen ein neues gesetz durch das
schwer kranken menschen eine bessere
versorgung zu hause sichern soll
franziska wunderlich fast ein jahr lang
wurde um ein gesetz gerungen dass die
intensiv pflege und rehabilitation
stärken soll
immer wieder besserten die
regierungsparteien nach doch bis zum
schluss blieben punkte strittig
vor allem der dass pflegebedürftige auch
gegen ihren willen in ein heim verlegt
werden könnten wenn vor ort
qualitätsmängel festgestellt werden
und seit demokratie dass man tatsächlich
auch seinen aufenthaltsort frei
bestimmen kann und wir sehen dass durch
dieses gesetz gefährdet es geht um
menschen wie marlen die 22-jährige hat
mosley eine seltene erkrankung des stamm
hirns unheilbar und unaufhaltsam
mittlerweile kann sie nicht mehr laufen
sprechen atmen ein ambulanter
pflegedienst ist rund um die uhr für sie
da
denn dass man den in einem heim betreut
wird ist für mutter und tochter und
denkbar
die zeit nicht so zu genießen wie wir es
kennen dass man zueinander findet
wandern will und kann
das finde ich nicht schön rosemarie
hofmann sorgt sich da die
qualitätskontrollen vom medizinischen
dienst im auftrag der krankenkassen
durchgeführt werden
also denjenigen die die kosten und
personal intensive pflege zuhause zahlen
müssen
in einer letzten änderung anfang der
woche meldeten cdu und csu diesen punkt
noch einmal ab dem wunsch dem interesse
des pflegebedürftigen zu entsprechen
geheim bleiben zu können
und das muss man in übereinstimmung
bringen mit der häuslichen situation die
eben auch geeignet sein muss bei den
hoffmanns bleibt der zweifel ob das so
genannte intensivpflege und
rehabilitations stärkung gesetz
tatsächlich auch die betroffenen stärkt
der umstrittene fleischfabrikant tönnies
hatte einen prominenten berater den
früheren spd chef und
wirtschaftsminister sigmar gabriel
nach informationen des ard magazins
panorama hat gabriel von märz bis mai
dieses jahres führt turniers gearbeitet
und dafür 10.000 euro im monat bekommen
als minister hatte er die
arbeitsbedingungen in vielen
schlachthöfen 2015 noch als schande
bezeichnet die unternehmen hatten
daraufhin besserung versprochen
führende spd-politiker haben gabriel
heute heftig kritisiert er selbst sagt
er sei kein politiker mehr es gebe weder
ein rechtliches problem noch einen
interessenkonflikt
unser nächstes thema die zahl der korona
toten in deutschland insgesamt ist auf
9000 4 gestiegen nach angaben der johns
hopkins universität stand heute vor
einer halben stunde bei den
neuinfektionen bleiben die zahlen stabil
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 430 menschen täglich neu mit
dem virus angesteckt erschreckende
corona zahlen kommen aus den usa
erstmals haben sich in nur einem tag
mehr als 50.000 menschen neu angesteckt
ein trauriger rekord
das ziel flat der curve die kurve
abflachen rückt damit wieder in weite
ferne
noch mitte juni waren die täglichen
neuinfektionen rückläufig doch seit
vergangener woche steigen sie wieder
deutlich viele bundesstaaten hatten ihre
beschränkungen früh wieder gelockert
mehr von ihnen des trans sie sind am
anschlag ein krankenhaus in san antonio
texas die intensivstation voll belegt
sie dachten sie hätten die pandemie im
griff doch dem ist nicht so
es kommen mehr patienten denn je viele
jüngere die sehr krank sind betten und
beatmungsgeräte reichen nicht aus
gestern war der schrecklichste tag für
mich wir hatten zehn eingängen junge
leute für alle wäre die
beatmungsmaschine richtig gewesen ohne
die würden sie sterben so krank sind sie
aber davon habe ich nur 337
us-bundesstaaten haben deutlich
steigende infektionszahlen zu schnell
wollte man alltag und wirtschaft wieder
hochfahren
nun werden bars und restaurants erneut
dicht gemacht strände vor dem großen
nationalfeiertag gesperrt die menschen
zwiegespalten
ich finde das nicht okay dass wir nichts
machen dürfen erst recht an diesen
großen tag an dem wir unsere
unabhängigkeit feiern
wenn die leute sich nicht zusammenreißen
dann werden wir ewig damit zu tun haben
präsident trump spielt derweil die
infektionszahlen herunter stattdessen
lobt für einen sich erholenden
arbeitsmarkt 80 prozent der
kleinunternehmen sind offen wir werden
in den kommenden monaten gute
wirtschaftszahlen sehen denn weitere
unternehmen werden folgen gerade weil
wir während dessen die flamme des virus
löschen
während das land vorsichtsmaßnahmen
plant bleibt dabei er lädt zum
nationalfeiertag viele menschen nach
washington um feuerwerk und überflüge zu
bestaunen und damit guten abend nach
washington jenes verheerende zahlen aber
gerade gesehen in den usa gibt es dann
einen konkreten plan das in den griff zu
bekommen
nein den gibt es nicht und wie wir aus
dem weißen haus hören hat man in den
vergangenen tagen im beraterkreis rund
um präsident trump diskutiert ob er
überhaupt auf die explodierenden corona
zahlen verstärkt eingehen soll oder ob
er weiterhin bei seinem fokus bei seinem
fokus auf die wirtschaft bleiben sollen
ich denke dass presse statement von ihm
heute zeigt ganz klar er setzt weiterhin
auf das thema wirtschaft auf das
hochfahren der wirtschaft das virus
die pandemie redet er entsprechend klein
und entsprechend propagiert er eben auch
nicht einfachste vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie
social distance singen oder maske tragen
dass bei dieser vorgehensweise aber
werden die zahlen die infektionszahlen
auch die todeszahlen weiter in die höhe
schnellen
diese vorgehensweise könnte also für
tanz wahlkampf verheerend enden aber
erst recht auch für das gesamte land
indes vielen dank nach washington
vor allem eins braucht die eu in den
nächsten monaten nämlich eine starke
politische führung sagt die
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen angesprochen kann sich die
bundeskanzlerin fühlen zu beginn der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft das
problem noch haben die mitgliedsstaaten
recht unterschiedliche meinungen wohin
sie die eu führen soll
heute gab es erst mal ein video gipfel
zwischen der kommission und dem
bundeskabinetts gunnar krüger berichtet
der auftritt von bundeskanzlerin und
kommissionspräsidentin ist schon fast
synchron
ja liebe ursula winke winke von berlin
nach brüssel zwei deutsche frauen stehen
vor der presse und an europas spitze
jeder tag zähle nun beim ringen um den
eu haushalt ist das deutsche duo zu
europas vorteil
ich finde
früher haben dass zwei männer immer
geschafft jetzt müssen wir das als zwei
frauen schaffen und wir sind da ganz
selbstbewusst dass wir das auch
hinkriegen glaube ich nicht warum sie
das gute ist wir kennen einander lange
wir vertrauen einander tief und das gute
ist dass wenn man sich sehr kennt kann
man auch sehr effizient sehr klartext
sprechen was auch nötig ist denn die
aufgaben sind grundverschieden
die eine macht vorschläge wie den
milliardenschweren ausbau planen die
andere sucht dafür die zustimmung unter
26 kollegen europas macht liegt bei
kommission parlament und rat in der rats
präsidentschaft setzt deutschland die
themen der minister räte im rat der
regierungschefs hat dabei michelle den
ständigen vorsitz merkel soll nur
unterstützen
tatsächlich soll sie das kunststück
vollbringen und europas wirtschaft
ankurbeln ohne dass es die eu
auseinander reißt am besten kann das
gelingen wenn beide frauen in ihrer
rolle bleiben und jeden eindruck von
kumpel vermeiden
beweisen können dass beide beim nächsten
präsenz gipfel in zwei wochen dann muss
auch keine mehr winken die
volksbefragung zur verfassungsänderung
in russland ist ein sieg für präsident
wladimir putin heute am tag danach
wächst die internationale kritik die eu
kommission spricht von
unregelmäßigkeiten bei der abstimmung
und fordert eine untersuchung nach
russischen angaben stimmten knapp 78
prozent für die neue verfassung sie gibt
putin mehr macht und ermöglicht ihm
weitere amtszeiten
so könnte er bis 2036 präsident bleiben
wer gerade urlaub außerhalb der eu
machen will steht vor großen problemen
für einige nicht eu länder werden die
krone reisewarnungen zwar nach und nach
gelockert
allerdings bislang nicht für die türkei
zum leidwesen der regierung erdogan
denn nach spanien und italien ist die
türkei das dritt liebste urlaubsland der
deutschen
4,5 millionen deutsche verbrachten dort
2009 10 ihre ferien
genau deshalb ist der türkische
außenminister heute in berlin und
versucht seinen deutschen kollegen davon
zu überzeugen die reisewarnung für die
türkei
doch aufzuheben andreas köhlers
berichtet wie wichtig gerade die
deutschen touristen für die türkische
wirtschaft sind lässt bereits die größe
der delegation erahnen die an karat nach
berlin geschickt hat den außenminister
den tourismus minister und zahlreiche
hohe beamte des gesundheitsministeriums
alle mustergültig mit maske und mit
einem koffer voll mustergültiger daten
dabei aber die bundesregierung sagt noch
nicht wir werden jetzt im eu kreis im
rahmen unserer präsidentschaft im zwei
wochen takt entscheiden ob und wo
weitere lockerungen möglich sind und
unsere hoffnung ist dass es natürlich
bald zu mehr öffnung kommt aber noch
gilt die reisewarnung für nicht
notwendige touristische reisen noch
steht die türkei auf der risikoliste des
robert-koch-instituts rückkehrer müssen
mit 14 tagen quarantäne rechnen
masken pflicht und der lobby
fiebermessen an der rezeption die
türkischen richtlinien seien strenger
als die anderer staaten in die deutsche
reisen dürfen kritisiert die türkische
delegation neben dem außen auch im
wirtschaftsministerium und im
innenministerium auch die türkei fehlt
und da sagen wir dass das politische
entscheidungen sind dabei sollte doch
die wissenschaft im vordergrund stehen
dass das auswärtige amt neben
gesundheitlichen auch politische gründe
kennt nicht in die türkei zu reisen
sprach heute kein minister an
in myanmar sind offenbar mehr als 160
menschen bei einem unglück in einer
jahren gestorben
schwere regenfälle lösten ein erdrutsch
aus und verwandelten ein ganzes tal in
einem schlamm see
der unfall passierte im norden des
landes wo es viele solcher jahr dem
ihnen gibt myanmar ist einer der größten
lieferanten der schmucksteine die minen
sind oft unsicher immer wieder kommt es
dort zu unfällen noch nie wurde weltweit
so viel elektro schrott produziert wie
letztes jahr so steht es in einem
bericht der vereinten nationen
ausrangierte kühlschränke monitore
händen
dies fast 54 millionen tonnen brachte
der elektro schrott auf die waage das
problem nur rund 17 prozent des schrott
berges wurden recycelt viele kostbare
rohstoffe darunter gold und silber
landeten auf müllkippen oder wurden
verbrannt
der grund die welt kauft immer mehr
geräte die schnell kaputt gehen und dann
einfach weggeworfen werden
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung
beim sport und damit bei dir katja und
heute abend gibt es das erste
relegations duell zwischen werder bremen
und dem fc heidenheim
wer wird bzw bleibt erstklassig in die
zweite liga hat es gestern abend wieder
eintracht braunschweig geschafft ohne
allzu viel abstand untereinander
feierten fans und spieler in
braunschweig den aufstieg
nach dem schlusspfiff hatten sie noch
minutenlang auf die stadionleinwand
gstaad dann war es perfekt weil bayerns
amateure in münchen in der nachspielzeit
noch ein 2 2 gegen duisburg schafften
für braunschweig erzielte martin co
bilanz gegen mannheim 20 minuten vor
schluss den 3 2 siegtreffer doch das
alleine hätte nicht gereicht
ohne münchner hilfe keine aufstiegsparty
eine polizeisprecherin sagte der
deutschen presse agentur
es sei unmöglich und auch
unverhältnismäßig gewesen die
abstandsregeln durchzusetzen
am wochenende beginnt mit knapp
dreieinhalb monaten verspätung die
formel 1 saison mit dem großen preis von
österreich in spielberg sebastian vettel
stellte dort heute klar dass er davon
überrascht wurde dass ferrari seinen
auslaufenden vertrag nicht verlängern
will für ihn und alle anderen jedenfalls
gelten wie erwartet im fahrerlager
strenge hygienevorschriften auf vettel
und ferrari mercedes mit weltmeister
lewis hamilton oder red bull racing und
max verstappen die vergangenen tests
sollten vor allem neue abläufe
verinnerlichen jedes team muss mit rund
60 mitarbeitern weniger auskommen
masken sind pflicht wenn 15 meter
abstand unterschritten werden eine
tortur für die mechaniker wenn sie an
einem betriebs heißen formel 1 boliden
bei 20 19 teststationen sie da der
rennstrecke in spielberg aufgebaut
getestet wird alle fünf tage die
resultate folgen innerhalb von 24
stunden ein internationaler laborbetrieb
südöstlich von münchen hat diese
logistik aufgebaut die proben werden
rund um die uhr gearbeitet eine formel 1
ohne glamour mitverantwortung für die
heutige zeit es könnte der anfang wenn
es um den prozesses werden abwarten so
wir sind alle betriebs heiß und schauen
jetzt noch auf die tücken des alltags im
fernsehen
es kommt jetzt live gespräch in den bbc
nachrichten es geht um corona aber alle
gucken nur auf die tochter der befragten
wissenschaftlerin links im hintergrund
sie hat andere sorgen sucht den besten
platz für ihr bild mit dem einhorn der
moderator unterbricht das interview er
empfiehlt einen platz die kleine
scarlett schaltet sich dann selbst rein
wie heißt der mann will sie wissen
am ende sind alle glücklich scarlett
ihre mutter und kristin von der bbc und
natürlich die zuschauer das wetter noch
sind gewitter unterwegs es gibt eine
unwetterwarnung für bayern und baden
württemberg aber es wird ruhiger alle
details gleich von besten tully dann
empfehle ich ihnen das heute journal mit
dem kollegen claus kleber um 21 uhr 45
von uns allen hier chips und ihnen allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein stück und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter morgen sieht das wetter anders
aus denn dieses hoch hier
das dehnt sich aus und beruht das wetter
allmählich allerdings in der kommenden
nacht gibt es noch schauer und gewitter
vor allem im südosten deutschlands
schauen wir uns das mal genauer an die
gewitter entwickeln sich hier noch
zwischen den bayerischen wald und den
alpen
da kann es noch kräftig regnen unter
hase kann dabei seien sturmböen
ebenfalls lässt aber eine zweite
nachthälfte nach auch im osten gibt es
noch regengüsse mit blitz und donner
ansonsten lockert es von westen her auf
und die temperaturen sinken dabei auf 9
grad in der eifel und 16 grad an der
neiße
morgen gibt es relativ freundliche
abschnitte aus dem südwesten bis in die
mitte nach osten zum beispiel bis zu
oder ja unter scheint häufiger die sonne
im süden lassen die schauer nach im
nordwesten kommen neue schauer auf und
das bei temperaturen bis 25 grad in
sachsen anhalt und im rhein-main-gebiet
19 grad sind es an den alpen
das wochenende wird größtenteils
freundlich sein
im süden deutschlands nach norden gibt
es viele wolken schauer und ziemlich
viel wind die höchsten werte bis 29 grad
und der montag wird schon wieder
durchwachsener ein schöner abend